among the insurgent parties shaking up
the political landscape ukip and the smp
claim the headlines
but there is another force on the move
the green party is targeting a range of
constituencies and has got the major
players worried
first things first though they have to
secure their initial beachhead brighton
pavilion the seat that is home to the
uk's first green mp and a council with
the greens as the largest party
win here and they have a platform for
wider success lose and they may look a
flash in the pan
the people of brighton have way more
experience than the rest of us of what
it means to actually have green
politicians in power now though there
are voters up and down the country who
are wondering whether or not they might
fancy making a similar choice
so what would the people of brighton
advise well it hasn't been one long
honeymoon with the party the council in
particular has taken a hammering for
incompetence and mismanagement on the
streets though there are signs the green
love affair may be enduring
vote green i think a lot of people think
it's just a vote of
like a protest vote against other
parties but i think they've got some
good things to say what would be your
advice to people up and down the country
um i'd say
go for it i mean i think a lot of people
think they're a one-track party but
they're definitely like got a lot of
good qualities on like education i think
they're like their anti-austerity which
is a bit of a fresh air we would both
encourage people to vote green because a
lot of people say that you've had a good
mp but not a great council uh that's
true i've heard that
version of the issue because the green
council is run as a minority council
with caroline lucas is it about the fact
that she's just a really good
constituency mp or that she's a green mp
both
she is a very good constituent mp but we
need a green voice in parliament and i
think she supports that very well and
there was more where that came from
labour who are desperate to reclaim this
seat have a job to do
generally here and elsewhere if the
greens make waves it tends to be labour
losing out
even if they fail to claim other
constituencies by sucking votes mainly
from ed miliband's party they could have
a significant impact on the makeup of
the next parliament
you